a senior living community says they're
worried after finding out some have 90
days to move out the complex they're
living in being renovated now staff want
to clear the confusion some families are
feeling madison kimbrough has more from
both sides now at the complex right near
flamingo and mcleod madison
august first is when residents here at
rochelle pines were notified of these
renovations and for many that have
disabilities this news is causing major
concern
it's 17 years for
so many of us being here
we have no other place we know no other
place
and we're at an age where
just mopping the floor is an effort that
was a resident at rochelle pine's senior
apartments who didn't want to be on
camera but says she and her neighbors
are getting the runaround when it comes
to details regarding the move the
facility is asking residents to move out
so they can do some renovations but some
tell us the facility isn't being clear
about who is moving and where they will
be relocated there are also concerns
about the costs that come with the move
and who's responsible the daughter of
one of the residents says she was told
by her mother's neighbor that they don't
have enough income to afford the new
place and that they were turned away she
doesn't qualify so she can't move in
there
where are they going to put her there
here where are they going to put her
then are they going to move her into one
of the other complexes they told her no
because there's no openings other people
got to them first because you have 58
people that need to leave but nevada
hand the company who owns rachelle pines
says all of this is untrue stating that
no resident will be required to pay more
rent as part of any relocation effort
and that the company is covering all
packing moving and utility connection
fees residents have until october 31st
to move out with it taking 16 months to
complete renovations but many believe
those who are in bad health shouldn't
have to leave we watch for each other
we've always been close
and they don't understand that to them
we're just a number
as for residents relocating after the
renovations nevada hands shared that
they cannot guarantee that every
resident will get the same unit once
they move back in reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now matt